cy young winner shane bieber
up the middle off the mound and into
center field and arise spanx of bay's
head
runner goes and it's a strike amount
but now off the bag and now arise curls
up holding his right shoulder
this does not look good
donaldson taking
the ball right down the middle and now
it looks like something has happened to
luisa rise in his right shoulder and
he's walking off the field immediately
two down and now kepler with a drive
left center field back
and
off the wall
and kepler goes to second with a
stand-up double
well arise
is in better shape than we thought it is
his throwing shoulder and we'll
wait and see whether he can come out and
play defensively or not
breaking ball foul tips and no strikes
out twins get a couple of hits didn't
score may have lost the player we'll see
when we get to the bottom of the inning
quinta maeda
making his ninth start of the season
three and two to rosario jose ramirez on
deck
and
floated up there
got a swing and a miss two away
friend male reyes oh for three last
night
two down no score reyes sends a drive
deep right center there she goes gone
into the bullpen
his fourth career home run off kenta
maeda
and fran miel reyes has put the tribe on
top
two to nothing
with a thunderous
two out two run home run
into the bullpen in right center
sedillo kicks out his left leg and the
o2 pitch he got him strike three another
splitter and bowers had no chance
second strike out for kenta quickly two
down cleveland by two
there's a fair ball down the left field
line it kicks off the sidewall but it's
an easy double
for ahmed rosario with two outs here in
the second boy that was a thing in
beauty right down the line two out
double now put you in scoring position
at least give hedges an opportunity to
get you in
two-nothing tribe good battle here
hedges and maida
and the 2-2
swung on a little bloop job into right
center it's a base hit
that'll score rosario and austin hedges
had a tremendous battle and he won it
with a two odd rbi single to right
center and the indians have a
three-nothing lead
here's donaldson representing the tying
run
donaldson punches it to right naylor is
there
tagging as ref schneider he's coming
home
and the throw is over the catcher
and backed up by bieber it's a sacrifice
slide for donaldson his 18th run batted
in and on the throw to the plate
arrives advances to second base
cleveland three twins one
two two
swing and a miss he struck him out
hedges holds on to the foul tip
and it's the third strikeout for bieber
man beautiful split in the dirt gets a
swing of the miss two down
but it's a setup pitch you're setting up
the next pitch
and a quick strike out of reyes and
miata's first one two three inning
[Music]
perfect part of the order for the twins
to draw even if not take the lead four
five and six miguel struck out swinging
in the fur
as this ball hit high in the air for
sonota deep center field ramirez back at
the track at the wall into the bushes
for a solo home run just straight away
center field
miguel stano makes it a 3-2 ball game
as he'll take a lap yet again at
progressive field
that's the sixth home run over his last
nine games his second career home run
against bieber that was a two-strike
fastball right down the middle
struck him out two away
fourth k for bieber
this one popped up
and sono looks to have room potentially
and he makes the catch
and tommy
tommy watkins
tried to save sonoma falling into the
dugout
and all he got it was a whack in the
head great focus right there from the
jail and
instead of him falling into the dugout
tommy gets a concussion
you see tommy kind of dissed him the
first time when he tried to shake his
hand
and he's like okay i'm forgiving you
that's nice
there's a ball right at bowers there's
one
and two a double play
second double play today that was a
strikeout throw him out in the first and
here we go a 3-6 double play
three pitches bieber strikes him out to
end the fifth that's five k's for shane
3-2 cleveland
the center going back as ramirez still
going back and
off the wall he can't find it
kepler will round second and go to third
and the twins have the time run 90 feet
away
swing and a miss hey struck him out with
a beautiful breaking ball and that's six
k's for bauer or for bieber excuse me
and one down here in the inning that
runner
still down at third base talk about
getting that runner home from third base
less than two hours still have another
opportunity and now it falls to the
rookie out of secure loft
[Applause]
and carol off delivers the clutch hit a
liner to right and we're tied
missed the curve ball a few pitches ago
and was all over the next one and now
they're loaded up and simmons will back
runners go payoff pitch swag and a miss
he struck him out by pulling the string
on a wicked slider
and simmons goes down
to end the inning the twins tie it but
leave them loaded
that'll bring up friend mail reyes
he pops up a breaking ball and now all
know fran mills hurt looks a
looks like an oblique he was letting it
fly
and i heard the grunt from up here
yeah my first thought was he he was
grunting because he he had a pitch to
him
yeah a number of times we've seen him do
that but that's
that's pain he's not going to stay in
here i i didn't think so you can't risk
it
they're loaded up for hedges
austin hedges is having a big day
pop-up
[Applause]
and simmons wants it
we go to the 10th inning
with the indians leaving the bases full
in the ninth
swing and a miss he struck him out
karen check case a pair here in the 10th
and we go to the bottom half tied at
three
[Music]
here in the bottom of the tenth against
alex colemay austin the hedges start
standing as the runner at second cesar
hernandez oh for four
hernandez deep right field down the line
good night tasar hernandez with a walk
off home run a two run shot